bob wilson is both brave and sensible
he's been a leader in the civil rights
movement since he was hardly more
than a boy in the early 1960s
that was not always a safe thing to do
back then
he is tough and principled and kind
is a master's degree in social work from
the university of pennsylvania
an ivy league institution
in the 60s he joined the civil rights
movement
from 71 to 73 he had he headed a major
project at the national
urban league on criminal justice in new
york city
in 1974 he became a resident fellow at
the american enterprise institute in
washington
by this time he'd been doing a lot of
thinking and he began to
build a movement of which he's now the
godfather
he's the inventor of the most promising
thing
in race relations in america today but
more than race relations
in assistance to people who've got tough
lives and haven't had a chance
he calls it the neighborhood empowerment
movement
and he brought this work uh a common
sense
observation that's too much forgotten
troubled areas can be improved by the
same principles that are
work everywhere and they can really only
be improved by the people who live in
them
so he began to look for people who are
like that
we've just been reminiscing it's a
miracle
we're actually getting around to this
lecture because because he and i could
sit and talk all day
but we were remembering a particular one
of them that i knew very well
there was a man named leon watkins and
he lived in watts which is the
place where the riots started in 68 and
later in l.a
and he made the newspapers and i read
the article because
he put up wanted posters all over watts
with a picture of the head of the crips
a gang the bloods of the other big game
back then
and his name on it want it
you put his address on there and so the
day came when the
head of the crips drove up to his place
with an entourage carrying weapons
and he said what do you want with me
and leon says it's not i who wants you
it's jesus
i just i just i heard that story i just
loved that story
and so i went down and met him got to
know him but i went down and met him
through bob woodson
and he has helped the bill bob's just
telling me bob
woodson's enterprise that reaches all
over the country now
and it focuses on people who are heroes
and who are trying to build a decent
life on the old principles of what
decency is
and those principles are not black and
they're not white
they are what they are they're human
and i once you know i've always found
him an inspiring man
there's a fire that burns in bob
it warms everything he comes in contact
with for all the time i've known him
but it doesn't burn him up because the
fire is sparked by
love and he maintains that all the time
robert woodson
thank you
i have to say that this is the first
time in my life
that i've ever been introduced by
someone
who nearly brought me to tears
larry reminded me of how we met and when
we met
and the precious person of leon watkins
there is a prayer that i utter each time
that i speak and i commend to you
and that is god give me the strength to
tell and pursue the truth especially
when it's inconvenient to me
that if you want to go someplace that
you haven't been
you have to be willing to do something
you haven't done
or to put it another way if you keep
doing what you do
you keep getting what you got to quote
one of my grassroots leaders
george bernard shaw asked the rhetorical
question
must the christ die in every age to save
those that lack imagination
einstein said that imagination is more
important
than knowledge
ladies and gentlemen no at no other time
do we need moral imagination
in the defense of this country
as larry said i came as a veteran of the
civil rights movement
but i must tell you a little bit about
my journey i don't define myself as a
conservative
i can i define my political philosophy
as radical pragmatism
and i am a cardiac christian because
christ burns in my heart
and so therefore that
defines and so what i do then is look
for
allies that fits
into my mission and that is to serve the
least of god's children my life
is dedicated to serving the least of
god's children
the quality of any part person's life or
a nation is determined by how does it
affect the least of god's children
so when i'm looking for political allies
i look for people whose strategic
interests
are compatible with the strategic
interests of the least of god's children
and as a civil rights leader at the time
serving in westchester pennsylvania the
home of barrett rustin who was a
principal
advisor to king and they would come
through
our town to bring the press and we would
push our local issues
and i became disenchanted with the civil
rights movement as a young worker over
two
issues the first one was forced busting
for
integration
i i believed
that the opposite of segregation was
desegregation
that integration was an individual
matter
because i believe then as i believe now
that if you
in if you say the goal of is is is
integration then you are concluding that
anything is all black is
all bad
and so that got me in trouble with some
people because they said
well bob your position is compatible
with the john birch society and the klan
and my responsible well if i like
classical music and hitler does am i
supposed to not like classical music
you should take your position based on
what's right
and compatible with what you believe not
who agrees or disagrees
with your position the second
reason that i left the civil rights
movement is when we were
leading demonstrations outside of wyatt
laboratory a pharmaceutical company
and after two months when they
desegregated
and they hired nine black phd chemists
we asked these brothers and sisters to
join our movement
they said we got these jobs because we
were qualified
not because of the sacrifices of you all
out there picketing
and then i realized that we have a more
of a class problem
than we do a race problem
and so i realized that many of the
people who sacrificed most
in the struggle for civil rights did not
benefit from the change
because as dr king said what good does
it do to have the right to live in a
restaurant
live in a neighborhood of your choosing
or eat in the restaurant
if you don't have the means to exercise
or take advantage of that right so it is
not just
opening the doors we must invest in
people's
capacity to take advantage of what
opportunity is created
and i believe then that there was a big
split in the civil rights movement at
that time
because we of the poverty programs that
came along
at the time instead of being
a continued restoration force the way
the civil rights laws are built the
poverty program
proves to be a virus that was more
injurious
to the welfare of the black community in
this nation than anything that happened
between
the end of slavery up into that point
and that's a dramatic point
and i want to unpack that for a while
because i think
it is important because this nation is
in crisis right now
where everything is being divided
and as i said my my political philosophy
is
is is radical pragmatism that i am favor
and so my ask myself well what are the
policies that favor
the the the thing now the the left the
radical
left has convinced people that the
problems facing black america today
70 percent out of wedlock birth the high
crime rate
unemployment all the other uh
deficiencies
are as a result the legacy of slavery
and discrimination
that followed and so therefore
it culminated in the 1619 essays
in 2019 by the new york times headed by
the nicole hannah jones
that clarified all of that and said
america's real birth date is 16 19 1976
and therefore america is incurably
racist that racism is in its dna
and that white people should be shamed
blamed and punished
and white people should be black people
should be patronized
and paid
i don't and and therefore because the
founders some of the founders were slave
owners and therefore america's
capitalism
is built on a a slave topocracy
and so this is what is pervasive today
and so what we decided at the woodson
center
because the radical left
is using the legacy of slavery i would
say the perversion
of of that history
as the principal bludgeoned to destroy
the country
since they were using that messenger we
felt that the messenger should also look
like that
so we brought together 26
scholars and activists and
to defend 1776
as the real birth date of the country
and and so what we were offering not as
a counter debate
we wanted to offer a counter narrative
that was both inspirational and
aspirational
and therefore to teach the real truth
of this country that yes america
is not no none of us should be defined
by our birth defects
of slavery how many of you want to be
defined are the worst things you've ever
done as a child
none of you do because america
is about second chances america is a
country built on the foundation of
redemption
and so what we offered there for was in
this counter narrative
we went back to unpack that history when
and and so in our essays we demonstrate
that black america should not be defined
by slavery alone
but we should be defined by the
resilience
and self-determination that was in
evidence
in response to those oppressive
conditions
that most people don't know black or
white the history
of our response to oppression
there were one of our essays went back
and looked at the
the uh the records of six plantations to
see what was the state of the black
family
in slavery he found that 75 percent
of every one of those uh slave families
had a man and a woman raising children
there was a rush to marry legally right
afterwards
when there was a 75 percent illiteracy
rate among the slaves
that rate went down to 25 percent in
less than 40 years when the freedmen's
bureau sent
workers uh agents south to teach blacks
they said that the sabbath schools or
the church schools were doing more than
anything the government
can do never in the history of the world
did a people
reduce its literacy rate from 75 percent
to 25
in 40 years because of the self-help
efforts
undertaken by these freed slaves
is because they have these institutions
that stand between the government
and and in in the people that we call
mediating structures
when blacks were denied accents to
hotels
what we did was build our own
we didn't have insurance companies so
our churches had burial society
we tapped those funds to build hotels
we had the wallahaji hotel in atlanta
the carver and calvert hotel in miami
the saint teresa in chicago
we built that when we were at denied
access to colleges and universe we built
100 by the year
2025.
education gap booker t
washington partnered with uh
sears and as a consequence
rose and julius rosenwald was the ceo of
sears
he partnered with booker t washington
and he was going to manufacture schools
in his
plant book at d washington said we don't
want charity we want an investment
so he put up four million dollars and
the black community local groups raised
4.8 million in response
and together they built five thousand
rosenwald schools throughout the south
that operated and as a consequence of
building these schools
in 1920 the the education gap between
blacks and whites in the south was three
years it was eight years
for whites five years for blacks
because of the rosenwald school the
education gap
in less than 20 years closed within six
months
when we were a crowded classroom used
textbooks
half the budgets of white schools the
question is if we could close the
education gap
in the midst of segregation why can't we
close the education gap today
when many of those school systems are
being run by people
of of color
the whole issue of marriage we know that
what helped
blacks sustain themselves in the face of
slavery and discrimination
was that two parent households their
christian faith
and a commitment to self-determination
again let's look at the records let's
look at facts
because if we cannot make decisions
based upon fact-based truths
then lies become normal
the fact is that in 1930 and 1940
when racism was enshrined in the law
there was no political representation in
government
the black community had the highest
marriage rate
of any other group in society
elderly people as a consequence could
walk safely in their communities
without fear of being assaulted by their
grandchildren
the poverty rate in the black community
according to thomas soul in 1940
was 85 percent and in 10 years it was
reduced
i dropped my little thing
in 10 years it was reduced by
20 and then by 1960
it was reduced another 15 percent
up until 1965 uh two parent households
and the incarceration rate from the turn
of the century was just 20 to 25 percent
and so uh in in 18
1868 when a thousand blacks were fired
off the docks of baltimore maryland
they didn't march on washington
demanding jobs peace and freedom they
went to the
burial societies and blacks owned their
own railroad the chesapeake maine dry
lock and railroad company
that hired a thousand people including
white workers
and successfully ran a railroad from
baltimore to maine
in the city of chicago that you hear in
the brownsville
section you talk about redlining that
took place
in 1929 blacks owned 731
businesses and 100 million dollars in
real estate access
assets in what we call the black wall
street
this was true in most urban centers
remember
just a few decades away from slavery
only there were 20 blacks who were born
slaves who died millionaires
their attitude what what whether
sustained blacks
was not becoming bitter about their
circumstance
but working there is an example for
instance
about what i call radical grace that's
at the heart
of the black community there was a man
named robert smalls who was born in
sumter south carolina north carolina
he was born a slave he was working on a
supply ship
and when his master went to have dinner
on a friday night he stole away
with six of his crew members picked up
the families and put on his master's hat
and coat and went past five
southern garrisons and turned the ship
over to the union navy
he was celebrated throughout the north
and as a consequence of his brave
actions
lincoln permitted blacks to fight in the
civil war
well after the war he became a wealthy
businessman and under reconstruction
he served in the house of
representatives
and became wealthy and went back and
purchased a plantation on which he
was a slave and because
the slave master's wife and children
were destitute and she was delusional
he took them in and cared for them and
permitted her to sleep in the master
bedroom
because she didn't realize slavery had
ended
robert small is an example of radical
grace
in action and so
this is a history that is being kept
from this country and they're endless
examples
there were 20 blacks who were born
slaves who died millionaire one last
story and i want to
talk about how we apply all this
knowledge today
betty mason was born 1818 illiterate
mississippi
walked behind a wagon of her master
going from
mississippi to salt lake city he was a
mormon
she had three children she tended the
sheep one of them was by the slave
master
when she got there took six months
walking behind her wagon she went
then he moved to california it was a
free state she was
a freed she was a midwife she saved she
made 100
1.50 a day she saved her money for 10
years
purchased land in what is now downtown
los angeles
and made a commercial and when she died
she died a millionaire
and ended up being a philanthropist and
founder of the ame church there
the endless examples of only in this
system of ours could somebody be
born a slave and die millionaires and
live
this kind of property and so the
question is if people
could do what they did when whites were
at their worst blacks were at their best
and so but there are people who want to
conceal these truths and define
black america by the birth defect
of this of this nation rather than by
its promise
the conservative movement has
proprietary interest that is compatible
with this self-determination the
attitude that exists then
exists today larry talked about leon
watkins leon
was a robert smalls
he demonstrates that when you have
self-determination
a will to fight and belief in your god
that there's no barrier that can hold
you back
but what we must do ladies and gentlemen
is that we must apply old values to a
new vision
that the spirit of renewal that we've
got to take the
the the principles that operate on our
market economy and apply them to the
social economy
in our market economy only three percent
of the people are entrepreneurs but they
generate 70 percent of the jobs
entrepreneurs tend to be c students not
a students
c students come back to universities
like this a students come back to
universities like this
and they teach c students come back and
endow
because smart people have to have all
the answers before they
act and when they act the opportunity's
gone
but see students like me we can fail
get back up try again fail the second
time
and then the third time we get it that's
the level of self-determination
and grit like leon watkins did and so
ladies and gentlemen my
my message today is that if we are to
retake this country
from those who would use race to defame
us
we must not do so by having white papers
and arguing on fox against what the
other side is doing
we need a ground strategy
a ground strategy like george whitfield
who was went to pembroke
1732 in england
his father was an innkeeper he died and
so george
had to clean the the end where they
lived
he didn't have enough money to go to
college and a friend supported him
but he had to do sort of a work and he
served the wesley brothers
and at that time students at oxford
could not speak
to students who were upper class
but they established a friendship he
went on to become a famous
uh preacher and also did when he came to
this
to to the colonies he did more to unite
the colonies
than almost anybody but what george did
was he got
on horseback and rode to every single
colony spreading the word of god he must
have spoken directly to 70 percent
of all of the people in our colonies
which united us
ladies and gentlemen those of us who are
servants of god who wish to make a
difference
we've got to leave our hallowed halls
and go as george whitfield did
and interact directly with people who
are suffering a problem
but we also must identify people who
exemplify the virtues what the left is
doing now
is a parasite on the civil rights legacy
they're talking about justice for george
floyd
and hijacking the civil rights movement
and then they go to portland and burn
the bibles burn the flag
and then talk about against the nuclear
family
these are the most destructive and so we
believe
that in order for us to stand up we must
de-racialize race
and desegregate poverty but we're not
going to do this
by as i said issuing white papers or
complaining about what the left is doing
we have to join in partnership
with people who i call the josephs of
this world
and that the woodson center
when we were looking for a model about
how can people with wealth
and people who are poor come together to
form
a coalition to take back this nation i
found it in genesis in the book
of story of joseph joseph as you know is
from a dysfunctional hebrew family
and he was a little arrogant too
and he told his brothers and i saw you
bowing down to me but that's not the way
to endure yourself with your siblings
and of course you know the story how
they faked his death
killed an animal sold him to the
ishmaelites who were slave traders in
egypt
and he's found himself in the house of
potiphar
but he never became bitter and became
the best servant in the house of
potiphar
and he was very handsome young man and
potiphar's wife lusted for him and
wanted to have sex with him
but he refused because he had lateral
integrity and horizontal integrity
it would have been a violation of the
trust his master had
and also a sin against his god and she
sent all the servants out and said that
he tried to rape her when he ran
out and he was put in prison
where he became the best prisoner and he
rose
in the prison and he met the cup bearer
and the baker
interpreted their dreams and they said
they would help him
and they turned their backs on him one
day
the pharaoh had a dream that none of his
mbas or his phds could answer
and then the cup barrel said there is a
hebrew
in the prisons that has the ability
to interpret dreams so
joseph was cleaned up and brought before
us and said bow down to the god pharaoh
he refused
because there'd be a sin against his god
so pharaoh knew he had integrity
and when pharaoh said to him i
understand you can interpret dreams he
said no the last time i did that i got
in a little trouble
but he said god interprets dreams i am
merely the instrument of god's will
and he said there'll be seven years of
plenty followed by seven years of famine
save up 20
and appoint an overseer first time there
i
we had flat tax
and of course you know what happened he
appointed
joseph think about how powerful that is
first of all
the fact that joseph was treated
unjustly and imprisoned
but never became bitter
and joseph as a consequence of his
position of power
was able to save not only the brothers
who betrayed him
but the egyptians who enslaved him
and so for and so he is a powerful
muscle we use that as a model
to looking for solutions and that's what
i want to talk about what
solutions we go into the inner cities
and we look for the two types of josephs
we're looking for people
who are in poverty but not of poverty
they're people of do you say 70 percent
of the people
are raising children or dropping out of
school it means 30 percent are not
we go into there we look for people who
are raised the joseph's
in bible they're in poverty but not not
of poverty they're raising children
they're not dropping out of school in
jail
no one does research larry or documents
why they are able to achieve against the
odds
but we do they are the leon watkins of
this world
and then there's the other type of
joseph that we're prostitutes that we're
gangbangers
but through god's grace they had become
redeemed
and therefore they are powerful
witnesses to others in that environment
that redemption is available to you
if you just follow this course with leon
watkins as an example
four children living in this gang
neighborhood that has put his family in
the bathroom in the
gangs he reached out to 26 members of
the east side crips
and when they pulled up he walked up to
him he said what do you want he said i
want to talk to you about your life
after sitting on a trash can for three
hours
he had quake who's still around in bible
study
four days later he had all 26 members of
the gang in bible study
they went from being predators to
protectors
of that community and one day
leon got a call at two in the morning
they said hey we found
two people burglarizing our pharmacy
what should we do with them so leon said
what do you think you should do and he
said we should do them
he says no you're peacekeepers now call
the police
so there's a picture on the front page
of the l.a times
of these gang members with leon turning
over these burglars
and so they became a force for good
there's an examples of what josephs can
do around this country we did the same
thing in washington d.c
22 years ago there was an area called
benning terrace of 53 murders in a five
square block area in two years
i recruited the leon watkins or the
josephs
that had the trust and confidence of the
people
and a 12 year old boy was killed and so
i sent them into that neighborhood to
bring the warren factions to my office
downtown they came in separate buses
they had bulletproof vests on
we gave them a meal because kids will
fight when they're drinking together but
not when they're eating together
and they said no one ever asked us to be
peaceful well through a series of
meetings
they shook hands and they went back into
that community
that they used to terrorize now as
ambassadors of peace
because once they their charac their
character character changes
the characteristic has an advantage
and so i say 80 percent of my closest
friends have letters in front of their
names not behind them
but if but if we can just unite the
pharaohs and the josephs
they are the ones in these communities
82
of black surveys are against defunding
the police
sixty percent of black surveys do not
believe racial discrimination is a
principal barrier
to their up but they are not given a
voice
[Music]
they are the josephs out there
and there are people falsely claiming to
represent them
and as a consequence their actions are
being perverted
so what we're doing we started something
called 1776.
we are going around the gatekeepers and
giving voice
to the voiceless and this is what's
going to unite america low-income blacks
are america's new patriots
because they are the ones suffering the
most from the vilification of police
we brought together a group called
voices of black mothers united
two thousand five hundred of them who've
lost children to urban violence
and they are the ones who took out a
full-page ad that says
we are not for defunding the police
it's important ladies and gentlemen for
america
to to move race because america is a
moral and spiritual freefall
that is consuming young people across
race in class
the leading cause of death of young
people
in in a city is homicide the leading
cause of death
in appellation among low-income whites
is prescription drugs
and the leading cause of death in
silicon valley
is suicide the suicide rate among teens
in silicon valley is six times the
national average
where there are two parent households
with master's degrees with a median
income of 180
000 so it isn't just family composition
or
so what our plan is to bring together
people across race and class line the
mothers
of appalachian mothers uh silicon valley
motors and inner city mothers
to come together to find out how can we
exchange
strategies to promote healing and
overcoming
and what lessons can we teach those to
prevent
children from but we won't do that as
long as we're being separated by race
and so those are the kinds of coalitions
that we are are seeking to
and we need the pharaohs and the josephs
to come together
and that's why i wanna what we need
larry that needs to be a university
we as conservatives we spend too much
time doing failure studies
that's why we have the reputation of not
caring about poor
and black folks you can learn nothing
from studying
failure except how to create failure
and so what we are recommending
is that scholars go into low-income
communities and report on resilience
find out how many people there's an
example
there's a mother for three years she has
two daughters
sleeping in the back of her car and
sleeping in homeless shelters
the girls were studying by the light on
the cell phone
one graduated saluted victorian the
other graduated
valedictorian they started spelman
college as sophomore because they took
so many advanced placement classes
why don't we know who they are
there was an 18 year old black homeless
boy
who borrowed his brother's bike and for
six hours bicycled across the state of
georgia in august
only to pitch a tent on the grounds
of a community college that he attended
the
year before and two white police
officers came over
asking what he was doing and once he
found out they put him up in the motel
and they wanted to get him a job and get
the
owner of a hotel of a restaurant to give
him some money he said i don't want
money i want a job so he started washing
dishes
well someone posted his experience they
raised eighty thousand dollars in three
days
he had a press conference to thank
everybody the president of the college
allowed him to move on campus
and now he's using that money to support
himself
the endless examples of
grace in action in our society where
people are coming together to help one
another
that deep in the dna of this country is
that desire to reward the virtues of our
founders
when a homeless man in boston found uh
eighty
uh forty thousand dollars in a knapsack
and he turned it in and this was posted
ninety six thousand
in three days there are endless examples
ladies and gentlemen
but we don't have anybody on our side
focusing on the promotion
of of health again
let me conclude by saying the answers
exist
but we have got to join with the josephs
of this world
but what's preventing us from doing so
is classism elitism
there is a lot a lot of people both left
and right of center
who believe that untutored means unwise
and therefore they have little to
contribute
in our market economy we don't care
whether bill gates ever went to college
we just care about what he produces
in our social economy if you got the
right credentials
you can waste million dollars if it's
well intended by well-credentialed
people
and so we need to apply some of the of
the of the
principles in the market economy as i
said
the market economy we reward outcomes
in our social economy we reward
credentials
there was a man who's one of my favorite
he died
not too long ago a.d gaston he was
alabama's first black millionaire
he had a sixth grade education and 80 80
gaston said it's better to say
i is rich than i am poor
and that is a metaphor for everything
that i'm trying to tell you
that don't
get turned off if someone speaks to you
and they dangle the participle or break
a verb
listen to them anyway because sometimes
the josephs can bring us the wisest
solutions
even though it may come in an
unvarnished package
god speaks to people in different ways
but ladies and gentlemen
this nation can only be saved when the
good pharaohs and the josephs come
together
and we determine what government will do
it won't come the other way but in order
for us to
develop that level of cooperation we
must lower our pretenses
shed the the the limits that we have
and what we believe in in other people
i just want to close with a quote from
samuel adams and he wrote february 12
1779
he said a general dissolution of
principles and manners will more surely
overthrow the liberties of america
than the whole force of a common enemy
while the people are virtuous
they cannot be subdued but when they
lose their virtue
they will be ready to surrender their
liberties to the first external or
internal invader
if virtue and knowledge are diffused
among the people
they will never be enslaved and this
will be their great security
neither the wisest constitution nor the
wisest laws will secure the liberty and
happiness of a people
whose manners are universally corrupt
that we can't just say we need lower
taxes
limited government if you want limited
government
then support the institutions that the
people use
that prevents them from needing
government
and expectations should be followed with
the means
of providing me to meet the expectation
and so we as conservatives have to
understand that
that we must leave our comfortable
places and go out
as larry has done learn to
identify respect
support and learn from and serve
the least of these god bless you